vuelco electoral hacia la derecha en
España en los comicios municipales y
regionales el domingo y vuelco a la
agenda política nacional de los próximos
meses tras el inesperado anuncio de
disolución de las Cortes y de
convocatoria de elecciones generales
anticipadas para el 23 de Julio en una
declaración institucional desde el
Palacio de la moncloa de menos de 3
minutos el presidente del gobierno de
España Pedro Sánchez ha asumido
personalmente la derrota del psoe y
considera que la respuesta a estos
resultados es someter su mandato
democrático a la voluntad popular
Alberto Núñez feijo líder de la
oposición y del partido popular asegura
que España está convocada a derogar el
sanchismo el 23 de julio y pidió una
mayoría Clara y contundente un resultado
que necesitaría el partido popular para
no tener que formar coalición con la
ultraderecha de vox como ha de hacer
ahora para gobernar en varias regiones y
ciudades españolas la maquinaria
electoral se pone en marcha y de
gobierno de Sánchez podemos muy mal
parados el domingo tienen unos 10 días
para anunciar si se presentan a las
elecciones generales en coalición con el
proyecto sumar de la vicepresidenta y
ministra de trabajo Yolanda Díaz que es
la política mejor valorada del país en
estos momentos para que así la
ciudadanía progresista tenga nuevas
opciones en las urnas la campaña
electoral en España empezaría el 7 de
julio una semana después del inicio de
la presidencia española de la Unión
Europea un mes en el que además se
celebran la Cumbre de la otan y El
encuentro entre la Unión Europea y la
celac